i am back
so where were we we were saying what if
we you know we know that that accelerate
the
velocity or the kind of the change in
velocity is acceleration times time and
i just wrote that a little bit for more
formally
really kind of incorporating the change
in velocity right the final velocity is
equal to the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time i actually could
have written it like this i could have
written vf
minus vi
is equal to acceleration times time and
this is the change in velocity right and
actually that's the way i should be
doing it as you can tell i i kind of do
some of this stuff on the fly
but but i do that for a reason because i
want you to get the same intuition that
that i hopefully have
instead of just kind of doing it in a
very formal way in a book and sometimes
the book doesn't necessarily make
the connections in the most natural way
so i'm this is going straight from my
brain to this video and hopefully into
your brain
so you know these are all ways of saying
the same thing i actually should write
this as you know change in velocity
the change in velocity that that
triangle or delta just means change so
the final velocity minus initial
velocity is equal to acceleration times
time
and the average velocity we should just
figure out you take the final you take
the initial and you average the two
is equal to
this
and then i said well we know what the
final
velocity is oh right this is the final
velocity right right the average
velocity is this
we substitute substituted for the final
velocity and then we came to this
equation for average velocity
and then before i almost ran out of time
i said i'm going to take this formula
for the average velocity and i really
encourage you to just play around with
these formulas yourself and derive it
yourself because it's going to pay huge
rewards later on when you forget the
formulas on your exam
but you can work it out anyway
so we have this formula for average
velocity let's substitute it back into
this so we can say that distance
is equal to the average velocity well
that's this
v
i
plus
a t over 2
times time
and if we just distribute that t we have
the initial velocity times time
plus
acceleration times time squared
over 2.
so distance is equal to the initial
velocity let me draw a line here not to
confuse things
distance is equal to the initial
velocity times time
plus acceleration times time squared
divided by 2.
and
some sometimes a physics teacher might
just teach excel a t squared over 2
that's sometimes what people memorize
and that's because a lot of these
projectile motion problems
your your initial velocity is zero
especially when you're you're dropping a
rock so if your initial velocity is zero
this term uh would would cancel out and
if you do that last problem that we just
did uh using this example you'll get the
same answer where what did i say i said
you know we're accelerating with gravity
so a is equal to 10 meters per second
squared
and then time is equal to two seconds
and then initial velocity is equal to
zero
so let me make some space here
so the distance is equal to the initial
velocity zero so this term just cancels
out
plus acceleration
meters per second squared
times time squared
so time squared not
actually that is i was going to say not
time square time oh no not time square
time squared
maybe someone should create another
square called time squared but anyway
you have 10 meters per second squared
that was a bad pun but
times time squared time is two seconds
so it's four and since we squared the
number we should also square the units
so it's 4
seconds squared
all of that
over 2.
and like we learned before well 10 times
4 divided by 2 is 20.
and then we have second squared in the
denominator here and we have second
squared in the numerator here they
cancel out and we're just left with
meters
that's actually i'm going to leave it
there for now and then in the next
presentation
i'll explore some of these
mechanics even further i'll see you soon